So, once again let's go back and
look and
detail the scale invariant detectors.
Let's first look at
the Harris-Laplacian.
Again, I've given a reference for those
of you who want to read more about it.
Basically, what is does is it finds a
local maximum of Harris corner detector
in space, in a Laplacian scale.
Remember, we've looked at how
to do Laplacians already.
So here basically is the best
way to kind of visually see it.
Scale is shown up this way, space is x,
y, that's where the images are.
Scale basically kind of captures
the frequency in the octaves.
First what I basically do,
is I run a corner detector in space
in the image coordinates, but
then I kind of move up in scale
by looking for the same features.
Using the Laplacians this time,
as I go from one scale to the other.
And that basically allows me to
find now at these different scales,
the feature does have the information
I want, if one scale or the other.
So just to reiterate,
in the scale which is up here and
then space which is down here.
In space, we are actually just running
a standard Harris corner detector, but
then we're using a Laplacian
in the scale space here.
So Laplacian in this, Harris in this
gives us the Harris-Laplacian detector.
Again, a widely used detector and
image processing computer vision and
computation photography.